good to see you
I mean
thank you thank you
you made it I didn't make it yet last
time we didn't quite make it but yeah
and before that I was sick and you came
I feel like we were passing ships in the
night yeah they're just different
accidents happening yeah yeah I know
either I have covet and you're covering
for me or there's a motor so there's
always an exit you're good you look
great though this is a brand new face
great job great job it's unbelievable
what happened I was working on a car and
I got a face full of gasoline and it
caught fire I had been eating a flaming
hot Dorito when I've been into it what a
commercial except my set my face on no
no but it was yeah it was it was it was
interest all third degree burns it was
pretty bad it was pretty bad you can't
tell at all no no you think there'd be a
zipper here or something but no no
that's
like a brand new only second time in my
career am I the new face of comedy I got
it once in the 80s and now I now I get
it again that's a brand new ear nothing
like a great Encore so so not too long
after your accident you got you got back
into stand up pretty quickly right
yeah I missed two days you know I spent
eight days in the hospital and they
managed to fix this all up it was pretty
amazing this uh Grossman Byrne Center is
on it's unbelievable and I lost it's a
great way to lose weight first you you
burn off the calories and then you're
going to crash diet on your motorcycle
and you and I dropped 20 pounds
it's fantastic The Optimist and of
course the tabloids get it all wrong
and the fact that I have smoother skin
powdery lips and a tighter butt has
nothing to do has nothing to do with
being in the hospital that was that part
was just coincidental natural exactly
exactly no but it's good it's good I
heard that is this sure that President
Biden like reached out to you he did you
know now
I mean those a long time yeah so a lot
of times you get a call from the
president United States and it's an
honor but the way it goes is the farm
hello is this Jay Leno this is the
London residence yes are you prepared to
take a call from the president United
States yes I am please stay on the line
you know and then I'll connect you with
President Obama or President Bush that's
how he does yeah so I'm in the hospital
phone rings hello Jay
oh Joe Biden president United States he
goes yeah I said where are you I'm in
China
I heard about I just want to assemble I
said I'm doing fine well I'm very
honored to call yeah no problem I just
just made me hilarious it's just
straight up called you you're just
straight away Jay it's Joe of course of
course that literally they he and his
wife called my mother yeah and because
we did this thing and it's about
teachers and they called my mother
nobody else called like you said like
not a representative for them literally
my mom was like hello and it was them
yeah and it was the craziest thing I've
seen I'm definitely like a man of the
people yeah he really is I liked Joe
very much a very nice guy so wait you
must have met a lot of presidents like
over your time so did you meet Reagan
did I hear that yeah when I was just not
in my career I got to the White House
correspondent that was a scariest one
the first time I did the White House
Correspondence Dinner like I'm backstage
and it's all political people and some
show people but
and I'm standing backstage in the wings
and Miss General comes in like this he's
got all the he goes hey you're the
community come in come here I go
okay that's the president United States
you understand that that is my
commander-in-chief he's doing this
that's my communities I go yes he's
doing that to you yeah he goes you don't
denigrate him you don't make fun of him
he is the president United States he is
my commander do you understand I'm gonna
tell you I said yes yes sir yeah okay
he's a big Huffer fine he leaves I go oh
man I gotta change my ACT here you know
you know
and then about about two minutes later
remember George Schultz Secretary of
Defense George Schultz come he's got a
drink he goes and he's like three sheets
to the wind at this point he goes Leno
come here come here
you get out there you nail Ronnie's ass
to the wall
totally different I don't want that
General I uh screw him he works for me
I'm telling you what to do you make fun
of that black thing on Reagan's head you
understand
do you understand what I want you to
nail him to the wall I don't know what
to do now now I'm like what did you do
oh I nailed him to the wall
him out they told you to yeah I I
remember the opening joke was uh was uh
I want to watch it Nancy Reagan I'm
being named uh humanitarian of the year
I'm glad she beat out that conniving
little Mother Teresa you know that
was a good joke but ranking
so when Reagan laughed at that then I
knew I was in it's like when they're all
watching is he think it's funny yeah
yeah when you do the wine that's what
they do they look at the president oh
and then they laugh that's exactly what
happened is it true that when you first
came to La you would sleep in open
houses like open houses well you know
what you can't do that anymore because I
don't think you were supposed to do it
before
well every house has an alarm system yes
but when I first came to La first thing
I did was buy a car it's either a par a
car or a place to live well you need a
car you're in L.A so I would just sleep
in my car and when I would go to open
houses that I open Sunday from noon to
four
so I get there at 3 30 look around the
house okay thank you realtor thank you I
slammed the front door then I go hide in
the closet you know I'd stand there
another half hourly hear the reel to
lock up and I would live in the house
for three or four days that's
and I never I never I never broke
anything I always made the bed dog and I
did that a bunch of times and then I was
standing at a beautiful house on
Coldwater Canyon where I later found out
was owned by one of the Beach Boys you
know so so I'm sleeping I hear the real
thing now in here here's a lovely room
s mommy there's a man in the bed oh my
God and I go oh sorry no skin what are
you doing here that's a real sense of
screaming sorry excuse me let me get out
of here please yes but actually it was a
great place you saved a fortune in rent
and you lived in
and I lived in beautiful I think it's
called squatting yeah yeah yeah yeah you
could say that yeah I think you do say
that yeah
you know President Obama once when I had
him on the you know I call them the week
he announced before anybody knew who he
was without him on The Tonight Show you
know and because everybody thought
Hillary had it in the bag you know so he
came in and you go Jay my name's Brock
was saying Obama I'm uh running for
president United States I said okay well
let's look at the odds here black guy
named Hussein from Chicago
nobody ever heard of him ah you're gonna
win pal you're going to be a shoe-in you
know and you know he was very funny he
had a great time
so he and I became friends and he gave
he gave me a cell phone number so I said
so I would tell one day I'm telling my
friend now you know how this is when you
come to a small town you have the same
Idiot Friends your whole life that you
grew up with yeah so I'm telling my
friends you know I got Obama's cell
phone let's call him up and we're not
going to call them you go you don't have
it
but like 45 year old men were going on
okay so finally my friend said no you
don't have it I said first of all it's
probably shut off
since he's president well if you shut
off let's call it I said what time it's
three o'clock in California it's 12
o'clock all right I dial the number I
hear Brock here oh Mr President yeah
it's Jay Leno what can I do for you Jay
uh should I throw this number away good
idea Jay
I was like you didn't have a plan I
didn't think he's gonna answer the phone
oh my God you have oh well I was just
calling about the crisis in and if you
needed any help like exactly oh my God
none of my friends care what I do they
don't care whose number I have I'm not
cool your friends still think you're
cool well no they don't really think I'm
cool but but you know it's pretty cool
to have brothers you have the same Idiot
Friends 100 yeah yeah I mean I'm not
calling them idiots shout out April Mary
I'm calling mine idiot
are doing is so freaking cool empowering
but I'm not the only one in fact our
official show mechanic was very
impressed as well he wanted to come out
and say hi so are you cool with that
yeah okay okay come on out
[Applause]
[Music]
I just back there working on Kelly's
truck
okay
and we are doing your attention
but angel I think this is so great what
you're doing because you know women
don't have enough to do now guys they
can work on your car so how about that
yeah
taking care of the kids and doing the
house now I can change your Island and
transmission fluid
at all it's fantastic how empowering
then
but we have some gifts for you I brought
these are Snap-on tools and a Snap-On
toolbox
[Applause]
and look to
draw
all kinds of got every possible tool oh
my God
oh my God
throw in a Jay Leno garage detailing kit
you got everything you want here
everything in here so wow oh my gosh I
love it and I think it might be fun I
know you guys are car enthusiasts I'd
love to show you my garage if you guys
get a kiss
he I haven't been there but we've you've
walked me through a tour of it once and
I was like oh my when he says for no
it's not a garage
it's an air hanger like an airplane
Hangar it's it's enormous you you well
it's a big garage
it's not it should not there should be
another word for your garage it's a guy
version of house a garage with a bed
attack
so if I was like I want to go with y'all
on the tour
um well um Angel uh Snap-on tools are
made in America and you're getting over
five thousand dollars worth of their
tools
[Applause]
and I am so happy to meet you too like
congratulations first of all 100 you
just turned 100. that's amazing yeah
and thank you so much for flying all the
way out here did you have a good flight
I had a wonderful fight you know when I
was on was jail a little time he always
sent me first class and you did too
we found out and we were like well we
can't not send her first oh no there's
always plenty of leg room from Audrey
right yeah I feel like we
deserve first class like I feel like
that's
so true you brought a throwback Thursday
photo for us right yes all right tell us
about it girl oh
[Applause]
oh yeah I remember yeah she was doing
friendly with me and then Tom Cruise
came on she left me for Tom Cruise and
then in a New York second you remember
oh you're just flirting I said hey quit
flirting with Tom Cruise oh you're so
handsome also you're cute hey hey what
am I trying to remember that yeah boy
you're still out there competing though
right oh absolutely and when I like I
fly home tomorrow the next day surgery
probably said I got a bake all day oh my
God
and she's competing with 75 year olds
so your cookbook is called the road to
Blue Ribbon baking yes correct all right
is this recipe in the book yeah the
recipe is in the book okay okay how do
we get started now right here in this
bowl okay I I I've already creamed
there's sugar and butter and vanilla and
eggs and borders you cream it really
lust because then that gets that nice
frying Grain coffee bro yeah all right
and so now it's time to add the flower
and then there was baking powder and
baking soda and salt it's all mixed
already and that's sour cream you start
with the flour say about a third of it
and then a third of a little bit at a
time and then keep going so I'll start
over there yeah right tell us how we can
all help but keep in mind right he's got
a hair because see when this when it
gets done the better it gets done you're
going to take it over here and then
we're going to put it in the in the pan
or have you know the batter then we're
going to put the rest of the batter on
top all right okay I'm gonna start look
watch this our first pupil was Sour I'm
getting it everywhere is that okay
you got you gotta stir that first I know
oh you don't let me put a little bit oh
of course I am quite the baker yeah and
then as soon as that gets mixed up put
in your sour cream okay okay you meant
trade off I thought you meant yeah
you really got this Kelly you're doing a
hell of it yeah
what a natural all right all right I'm
doing it I'm doing it a little bit at a
time people a little bit at a time is
this like right okay I'm gonna start
licking my fingers too because that's
how I do in the kitchen
wait what oh all right I'll be here you
know your way around the kitchen yeah
yeah I can sing real pretty sometimes
yeah okay yeah it's great it's going
everywhere yeah and then the rest is
sour cream and then that okay okay and
then we're going to get started oh what
he wants to do then this is your shoes
are all right well she's got She's Gotta
screw that up let's move over here
[Laughter]
flowers yeah so when Traders about her
here's the brown sugar right yeah you're
going to add some melted butter some
coconut some milk what do I put this in
in here right here I'll put this in
there everything will everything goes in
there yeah right it's supposed to be
supposed to be you melt the mother the
day before it doesn't
see this is what Kelly doesn't
understand she's never melted butter
yeah right here we go okay we got our
melted butter hey what are we doing now
baby
I gotta put the coconut in there yeah
and then mailing it yeah
stir that up here we go yeah right let's
help I like coconut juice yeah all right
[Applause]
Kelly you're the most confused person
yeah yeah I don't get in the kitchen
often I have a lot of jobs
we're going to put like a fourth of it
in here
yeah let's see that's the fourth here
and we gotta put a fourth in here all
right all right because they give us a
nice oh here's a knife right here this
thing this here yeah right put it up
with us here yeah okay well go ahead
Mark do you do it okay here we are are
you big into baking Bryce oh yeah yeah
sure absolutely yeah it's part of our
writer yeah
it didn't get spread here see if you can
spread that okay I can spread that okay
yeah it's hard to screw come on you're
slipping you're only a hundred get to
work
maybe if we put a little bit more a
little bit more in there there we go
yeah all right oh yeah now this way we
do it on TV watch we put it in the oven
down here like this no no it's not and
then it comes out
yet
no all right now we have to put the
street oh you got to put that on this no
or on this one I'll put that in there
I'll put some on each one okay there you
go okay
we gotta wrap it up
and look how it comes out right yeah
[Applause]
ah thank you we couldn't leave without a
small celebration because I wanted to
honor you because I think either you're
amazing and I'm so happy you came on my
show thank you very very much we have
something for you
[Applause]
I'm surprised
all right here we go
to you happy birthday to
Marjorie
happy birthday everybody
[Applause]
all right
I want to wish for 115. yeah
my first guest he's someone who will
always hold a very special place in my
heart because he was the first person to
interview me on TV after I won American
Idol and he's also my favorite host of
all time take a look I mean did you did
you think you would win were you that
confident you couldn't be modest but you
know what I'm saying did you because I'm
not sure when you when you enter these
contests do you have in the back your
mind I can win this you just try to go
week to week I mean I'm very day by day
I don't like to think too far ahead or
I'll start to stress myself out but um
you know nobody coming into this thought
this show for when I didn't think it was
gonna be that huge yeah and then nobody
thought you know you're gonna be the
winner one out of ten thousand yeah what
are the odds that's pretty good ten
thousand all right look look let's see
there you go
[Applause]
thank you
no no thank you thank you thank you very
much
I've always thought about that company
so the odds are winning are one in ten
thousand what are the odds and I said
well the odds are one in ten thousand I
know that's very simple question I at
least caught myself
what are the odds of that oh they're one
in ten thousand don't wait do you hate
watching interviews of yourself when
you're younger I don't even do it I
don't really want to sit to like
narcissus staring at my own reflection
oh yeah oh I
once in a while something comes up I
want to see you know an old star or
something oh God look at them I'm not
really looking at myself no no oh well
that's because you're awesome but that
was crazy that was 17 years ago just the
fact you said on TV I'm your first I
thought that was yeah
yeah it was so great
all right well we actually dug up um
because I love you so much I do I'm a
weird stalker love but anyway
um I found a picture from like the first
date since this is like the first season
for me I found a picture of you hosting
for the first time here we go look at
you
[Applause]
thank you
first
see I love now see anybody tuning in
right now will go whoa I didn't know
that I know that's how she got on the
show my husband yeah
well when you're good you're good
um no
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]